folks have been sending in for some
number of years now photos from towns
that they've been near that have [ __ ]
up names and we call this segment
appropriately your towns got a fucked-up
name actually we're revisiting one of
the town's we talked about previously
and this is our anniversary or a
birthday show I thought it was
appropriate this came from Don he was
actually in one of the town's we were
talking about is in the east coast of
Newfoundland Canada and it is called
dildo that is the name of the town enter
history
dildo it's like the instructions on the
box and we mentioned this previously on
the show and he said but you forgot to
mention that every year they also have a
celebration just like you guys are
celebrating tonight every for over three
decades they've been celebrating dildo
days and he said how did you not talk
about dildo days and he said however can
we punch in I would stay away from the
cup of childr and the dildo sticky
pudding Massa so now I [ __ ]
desperately want to go to dildo and
celebrate dildo days get some of that
chowder all over your face neck and
chest that's right get some sticky
pudding all over the dildo we all get
some sticky pudding
[Music]
you
[Music]